gigantisches insekten sterben einen
rückgang von bis zu 80 prozent mit droht
die menschheit unser thema heute bei
klicks um science-fiction forscher des
nabu des naturschutzbundes deutschland
warnen vor den drastischen folgen die
einen insekten massensterben mit sich
bringen wird
den forschern zufolge hat die umwelt
derzeit mit einem insekten rückgang von
bis zu 80 prozent zu kämpfen
und das könnte den tod für jegliches
leben auf der erde bedeuten es wäre
absolut dramatisch zitat unsere
beobachtungen in nordrhein westfalen
sind beängstigend wenn uns die
fluginsekten fehlen gerät die gesamte
nahrungskette in gefahr blumen und bäume
werden nicht mehr besteuert und
mauerseglern und schwalben fehlt die
nahrungsgrundlage sagte josef tumbrinck
das ist der landesvorsitzende des nabu
in nordrhein westfalen dass das
bienensterben eine große bedrohung für
unsere menschheit ist das ist quasi ein
alter hut und eben nur offenbar ein
kleiner teil des riesigen problem ist
einer studie zufolge gehen allein durch
die abwesenheit der bienen 23% früchte
16% des gemüses 22 prozent aller nutzer
orten und 22 prozent des getreides
verloren die prozentzahlen beziehen sich
alle auf den weltweiten bestand gehen
diese bestände in der folge zurück käme
selig zu 1,42 millionen todesopfern als
direkte auswirkung diese zahlen beziehen
sich aber wie gesagt nur auf das
bienensterben bei der meldung des nabu
geht es ja um alle insekten
die zahlen würden sich also
vervielfachen und wie schon gesagt den
tod für jegliches leben auf der erde
vielleicht bedeuten
wir können übrigens selber zu forschern
werden wenn wir uns einfach mal
überlegen wie sie früher im sommer eine
windschutzscheibe aus und wie sieht sie
heute aus wenn wir gefahren sind früher
war sie total verdreckt wir mussten sie
ständig reinigen und wenn man heute mal
übers land fährt merkt man da bleiben
viel weniger insekten kleben in der
pressemitteilung des nabu heißt es zitat
ehrenamtliche hatten zwischen 1989 und
2014 insgesamt 88 standorten in
nordrhein-westfalen fliegen insekten
gesammelt ihre arten bestimmt und sie
gewogen
während wir 1995 noch 1,6 kilogramm aus
den untersuchungs versammelten sind wir
heute froh wenn es 300 gramm sind so
tumbrinck der rückgang von bis zu 80
betreffe unter anderem schmetterlinge
bienen und schwebfliegen das gigantische
insekten sterben ist also kein ereignis
das uns in der zukunft erwartet der
ganze prozess ist schon längst in vollem
gange inka verlieren über den winter oft
große teile ihrer bienenvölker vielen
sind milden zum opfer gefallen die
varroamilbe ernährt sich vom blut der
larven und überträgt so auch krankheiten
auf die insekten forschern ist
aufgefallen dass das immunsystem der
honigbiene in den letzten jahren
schwächer geworden ist grund dafür kann
die anbau kultur der menschen sein
monokulturen also felder auf denen nur
eine sorte pflanzen angebaut wird
allerdings ist das immunsystem der
bienen noch ein sehr unerforschtes fällt
welche ausmaße das insekten sterben für
die menschheit und das ganze leben auf
der erde hat kann man bisher nur
mutmaßen schaut man sich die auf das
bienensterben bezogenen zahlen an ist
eins klar es wird lebensbedrohlich
schuld daran ist wohl auch noch niemand
geringeres als wir selbst
neben der einschleppung der milben
spielt der einsatz von chemikalien eine
große rolle zitat den klimawandel oder
besonders kalte oder warme winter können
wir ausschließen vieles deutet darauf
hin dass wir es mit einer weitreichenden
vergiftung der insekten in unserer
umwelt zu tun haben so leif miller
mit was vergiften wir also die insekten
neonicotinoide wie cleo tianyi dienen
imidacloprid und trug sein sollen
hauptverantwortlich für das insekten
sterben seien diese insektizide greifen
das nervensystem der sekten sekten an
und schädigen dieses dadurch enorm
obwohl der einsatz schon länger durch
behörden eingeschränkt wurde scheint es
noch immer genug schlupflöcher bzw
erlaubte verwendungszwecke zu geben dass
so viele insekten dadurch aussterben
aktuell prüft die europäische behörde
für lebensmittelsicherheit abgekürzt
wird sie efsa erneut den einsatz und die
damit verbundenen risiken solcher
insektizide mit einem ergebnis kann
allerdings erst anfang 2017 gerechnet
werden was sollen wir aber bis dahin tun
zitat die erhebung sind ein starkes
indiz dafür dass wir es in nordrhein
westfalen mit einem ökologischen
desaster mit weitreichenden folgen zu
tun haben wir brauchen neben wirksamen
und schnell greifende schutzmaßnahmen
parallel ein forschungsprogramm das den
ursachen dieser rapiden vor
atmung auf den grund geht und ihre
folgen für natur und menschheit aufzeigt
so josef tumbrinck ich kann nur sagen
bis dann bleibt dran
ein aktueller kinofilm bringt es jetzt
auf den punkt power to change rückt
einige argumente gerade und zeigt wie
einfach die energiewende auch sein kann
aber warum kommt die energiewende
weltweit nur relativ langsam ins rollen
der film zeigt den einfluss der
wirtschaft auf die politik was
unternehmen lobbyisten um ihre
wirtschaftlichen interessen vor die
energiewende zu stellen
beginnen wir erst mal mit denen die den
wandel zuerst und im großen stil
vorantreiben müssen politikerinnen und
politiker die politik die es deshalb
ausschlaggebend weil sie gesetze
erlassen kann politik beschließt auch
subventionen erneuerbare energien werden
zb in deutschland unterstützt allerdings
werden auch herkömmliche arten energie
zu erzeugen gefördert und das kann
unterschiedliche gründe haben
der kohleabbau zum beispiel hat vor
allem im ruhrgebiet ist er teil der
arbeiterkultur viele menschen hat nun
haben noch jobs im bereich der
kohleindustrie klar wenn man diese
arbeitsplätze einfach schlecht ohne eine
alternative für die arbeiter geschaffen
zu haben dann ist das eine sehr
unpopuläre entscheidung 2015 sei der
konzern rwe in nordrhein westfalen fast
100.000 arbeitsplätze bedroht da
wirtschaftsminister sigmar gabriel
plante co2 ausstoßen betriebe abgaben
zahlen zu lassen also eben
kohlekraftwerke nun damit so etwas nicht
passiert schicken die konzerne dieser
welt gerne lobbyisten los die ihre
interessen in den kreisen der politik
vertreten die einfluss auf die politik
ist dermaßen hoch dass lobbyismus auch
schon mal als die fünfte macht im land
bezeichnet wird auch die kernkraft
industrie hat ihre lobbyisten die
fleißig für die interessen der
kraftwerksbetreiber agieren natürlich
gibt es auch lobbyismus von
umweltverbänden ein gleichgewicht
zwischen den verschiedenen lagern
existiert aber nicht im film power to
change geht es auch über die
einflussnahme im internationalen bereich
als beispiel die ukraine
da sind die filmemacher in die ukraine
gereist um zu erfahren was politik und
internationale einflussnahme ausrichten
in deutschland werden inzwischen rund 30
prozent des stroms durch erneuerbare
energien gewonnen
vor ein paar jahrzehnten hat sich das
noch niemand vorstellen können
das klingt erstmal nach fortschritt
allerdings ist die lage so den
energieanbietern wurden co2 zertifikate
erteilt sie dürfen eu-weit eine
bestimmte menge co2 ausstoßen und wenn
jetzt in deutschland mehr windräder
stehen können den anderen europäischen
staaten dennoch kohlekraftwerke gebaut
werden eingespart wird co2 also nicht
automatisch neue energien kosten viel
geld man muss windräder errichten becher
mit solarpanel ausstatten
dagegen ist der etablierte atomstrom
doch eine günstige alternative könnte
man auf den ersten blick glauben aber
die mehrkosten sind eigentlich allen
bekannt genau heute an dem tag an dem
wir dieses video aufzeichnen jetzt sich
die reaktorkatastrophe von tschernobyl
zum dreißigsten mal vor fünf jahren kam
es zur katastrophe von fukushima und das
sind die bekanntesten aber nicht die
einzigen vorfälle bei denen sich zeigt
wie verheerend kernenergie sein kann es
gibt eine sehr sehr lange liste mit zum
teil verheerenden atomunfällen und
selbst wenn alles nach plan läuft
atomkraftwerke produzieren atommüll in
form von ausgedienten brennstäben
mischoxiden verstrahlten werkzeugen aus
den werken und sogar benutzte kleidung
der mitarbeiter 12.000 tonnen dieser
abfallprodukte entstehen jedes jahr
weltweit für den müll gibt es immer noch
seit jahrzehnten kein endlager in
deutschland experten schätzen dass die
suche nach einer geeigneten städte bis
sogar in die mitte des nächsten
jahrhunderts dauern könnte
ja man schätzt dass im jahr 2170 ein
geeignetes lager befüllt und geschlossen
werden könnte
die kosten für die suche sollen auch
noch ansteigen auf 50 bis 70 milliarden
euro
ja dazu kommen noch dimensionen die sich
ein einzelner mensch kaum vorstellen
kann das endlager soll sicherheit für
eine million jahre bieten aber selbst
wenn man sich die halbwertszeit der zu
lagernden stoffe ansieht die ja
wesentlich kürzer sind erkennt man wie
lange die menschheit mit der dazu im
verhältnis kurzen periode des atomstroms
zu tun hat plutonium 239 zb hat eine
halbwertszeit von 24.000 jahren also
plutonium benötigt 24.000 jahre damit es
noch halb soviel strahlt und setzt dann
ist plutonium noch extrem giftig es
braucht also x-mal 24.000 jahre bis
plutonium wirklich ungefährlich ist in
deutschland werden viele atomkraftwerke
beschlossen aber selbst solche gebäude
abzureißen dauert seine zeit und viele
teile der gebäude sind auch atome und so
ganz kommt die atomkraft ja ohne den
ausstoß von co2
auch nicht aus durch den abbau des
benötigten urans kommt es ebenfalls zur
produktion von co2 bei der aufbereitung
des uranerz kann es vorkommen dass die
energie hineingesteckt werden muss viel
höher ist als die energie die am ende
durch das atomkraftwerk produziert wird
in den abbaustätten stellt das relativ
schwach strahlende uran zwar keine allzu
große gefahr da allerdings können durch
den abbau schwermetall verbindung das
trinkwasser verunreinigen uran zerfällt
zudem zu radon einem edelgas das zu
lungenkrebs führen kann und den
abbaugebieten oder halben kann sich das
gas ansammeln es ist hoch los farblos
geschmacklos und kann deshalb unbemerkt
eingeatmet werden im film geht es
allerdings nicht nur um großkonzerne und
politik was kann jeder einzelne selbst
tun und mit kostbaren energie nicht zu
verschwenderisch umzugehen beispiel auto
statussymbol individuelle mobilität aber
muss es immer das eigene auto sein das
die meiste zeit des tages ungenutzt
herumsteht carsharing wäre eine
alternative und das ist schon seit
einiger zeit ein beliebter trend im
januar 2016 wurden in deutschland 1 2
millionen registrierte nutzer bei
carsharing unternehmen verzeichnet aber
einfach weiter mit verbrennungsmotoren
mobil sein
der welthandel mit erdöl hat negative
folgen sogar für uns jeder kann ein
wenig dafür tun dass wir einen wandel
nicht nur in unserem denken vollziehen
sondern auch in unserem handeln
ich selbst habe in den letzten jahren
auch einiges geändert der strom kommt
bei mir von einem ökostromanbieter ich
fahre rad zug straßen oder s-bahn und
fliege viel seltener und habe kein auto
mehr ich esse weniger fleisch kaufe
regionale produkte damit nicht so viel
transportiert werden muss und das
möglichst im biomarkt zusammenfassung
macht mit schaut den film an ändert was
tut was was ihr für richtig haltet
darüber dass sich etwas ändern muss da
sind sich eigentlich alle einig und wenn
jeder ein bisschen anders macht ist das
schon eine menge ich würden disclaimer
geben journalisten sollte sich nie mit
einer sache gemein machen das tue ich
hier auch nicht objektiv bedeuten
fossile energie und atomkraft das ende
der menschheit regenerative energie ist
billiger besser und schädigt unsere
umwelt viel weniger zudem gibt es keinen
anderen weg da nur sie mit abstand viel
ungefährlicher ist als andere
wer für kohle- oder atomkraftwerke ist
und gegen windkraft und gegen
sonnenenergie und so weiter
der sollte sich nochmal schwer überlegen
was die folgen sind wie krieg krebs
umweltverschmutzung klimawandel und so
weiter bisher entferntes des wasserstoff
signal aufgespürt wasserstoff massen in
einer sehr weit entfernten galaxie und
mit ihr geschieht gerade etwas
spektakuläres jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction
forscher aus den usa haben im zuge des
kosmos heirat extra galactic server mit
dem very large area telescope kurz vl
spuren von wasserstoff in einer fünf
milliarden lichtjahre entfernten galaxie
aufgespritzte tat dies ist das erste mal
dass wir atomarer wasserstoff in einer
galaxie so weit weg von der erde direkt
messen konnten sagte seminar fernandez
von der rutgers university in new jersey
der bisher am weitesten entfernte
wasserstoff emissions- und die gerade
mal für beiden entfernung von drei
milliarden lichern in der fünf
milliarden lichtjahre entfernten galaxie
achtung komplizierter name kosmos lässt
es selber konnten die wissenschaftler
aber nicht nur ein bisschen atom an
wasserstoff finden sondern sehr sehr
viel davon und dazu noch molekularen
wasserstoff im laufe des videos nennen
wir die galaxie übrigens einfach nur
kosmos ich glaube dass es etwas
einfacher und wie viel wasserstoff wurde
da jetzt gefunden
es sollen jeweils rund 30 milliarden
sonnenmassen in der galaxie kosmos von
beiden wasserstoff arten entdeckt worden
seien also molekularen und atomen aber
was ist der unterschied also was ist
molekularer und was ist atomarer
wasserstoff und vor allem was ist so
besonders daran atomarer wasserstoff ist
ein einzelnes wasserstoffatom h1 ein
relativ freies radikal und kommt eher
selten vor molekularer wasserstoff
besteht aus mehreren wasserstoff atomen
die sich leicht durch elektrolyse zu
diesem stabilen h2 zusammenfinden jetzt
kommen wir zur besonderheit molekularer
wasserstoff kann mit viel energie
aufgespalten und zu atomarem wasserstoff
umgewandelt werden um ein einziges
wasserstoff molekül aufzuspalten braucht
man rund 4 elektronenvolt
problematisch bei der umwandlung ist die
instabilität der atomaren
wasserstoffteilchen sind
reaktionspartner in der nähe reagiert
atomarer wasserstoff rasch und sehr
gewaltig mit diesen das heißt so viel
wie atomarer wasserstoff bleibt nicht
besonders lange atomarer wasserstoff im
weltall dagegen besonders in der nähe
von galaxien kann atomarer wasserstoff
viel länger in dieser form überdauern
die strahlungsenergie der jetzt
entdeckten galaxie schafft es so viel
die aufzubringen um milliarden atomare
wasserstoffteilchen isoliert zu lassen
und das sind jetzt nur auf den atomaren
wasserstoff bezogen rund 120 milliarden
elektronenvolt ziemlich viel könnte man
sagen
dank der gewaltigen energie die diese
galaxie aufbringen konnte die überhaupt
erst entdeckt werden zitat diese signale
begannen ihre reise noch bevor unser
planet existierte nach 5 milliarden
jahren der reise durch das all sind sie
nun in unseren teleskopen gelandet und
erlauben es uns diese galaxie zum ersten
mal zu sehen beschreibt fernandez
faszinierte entdeckung neben der energie
ist die unterschiedliche wasserstoff
dichte in bzw an den äußeren rändern der
galaxie kosmos auffällig seitens der
forscher heißt es dazu zitat während die
galaxie optisch ungestört aussieht
spricht die asymmetrische verteilung des
neutralen wasserschloss dafür dass es
eine interaktion mit einem möglichen
begleiter gibt zitat ende kosmos könne
sich also bald mit einer anderen ähnlich
außergewöhnlichen galaxie vermischen
das ist spektakulär um kostenlos
überhaupt zu entdecken beobachteten die
forscher und 178 stunden das weltall
da man jetzt ein hinweis auf eine zweite
galaxie gefunden hat bleibt den experten
eine solch lange suche voraussichtlich
erspart um die zweite galaxie zu finden
die älteste bekannte galaxie ist
nebenbei erwähnt ungefähr 13 4
milliarden lichtjahre von unserer erde
entfernte galaxie bmz 11 entstand dabei
tatsächlich nicht nur vor unserem
planeten sondern zu einem zeitpunkt
nehmen das ganze universum gerade mal
drei prozent seines jetzigen alters
erreicht hatte da war der urknall gerade
mal 400 millionen jahre her
wer mehr dazu erfahren will kann gerne
mal hier oben auf das i klicken dann
kommt ihr zu einem video dazu und wenn
euch dieses video gefallen hat dann
freue ich mich über einen einen daumen
nach oben
und natürlich wenn er ein kostenloses
abo dallas schreibt in die kommentare
ob ihr euch einen job im bereich
gastronomie vorstellen könnt ich finds
ja unglaublich spannend 178 stunden wird
man da hoffentlich nicht immer ins rohr
gucken müssen gehirn implantat
entwickelt ebola fall in liberia und
touristen schon im jahr 2008
das sind drei der fünf themen jetzt in
den krieg zum topf news
gehirn implantat entwickelt
verantwortlich dafür ist die defense
advanced research projects agency
abgekürzt dabei die dabei ist eine
behörde des us verteidigungsministeriums
daher ist nicht ganz verwunderlich dass
das neue implantat menschen die im krieg
oder auf andere art und weise
gliedmassen verloren haben dabei helfen
soll prothesen steuern zu können im
fachmagazin nature berichten forscher
der darpa über ihre forschungsergebnisse
mit hilfe des im platz konnten sie ganz
ohne operation die gehirnaktivitäten von
schafen messen und beobachten das
implantat ist circa 30 mal fünf
millimeter groß und wird ganz
unproblematisch durch eine ader am hals
in den körper gemacht es handelt sich
hierbei um eine centro de stents
verwendet man unter anderem um
blutgefäße offenzuhalten gemessen wurden
bei den versuchstieren insbesondere die
aktivitäten die bei bewusst
durchgeführten bewegungs prozessen
getriggert werden ganze 190 tage konnten
so daten gesammelt werden wird in der
forschung ein implantat eingesetzt gegen
das bisher fast immer mit einer ziemlich
risikoreichen operation einher am
menschen haben die forscher ihre
errungenschaften jetzt noch nicht
getestet aber die ersten tierversuche
die waren mehr als vielversprechend im
nächsten jahr könnte das implantat aber
schon mit den ersten menschlichen
probanden getestet werden drei sonnen
rücken einen planeten ins rechte licht
wissenschaftler des harvard smithsonian
center für astrophysik abend
sensationelles über den planeten hält 4a
b herausgefunden hält ghb ist ihrem
artikel im fachmagazin erst von oracle
journal zufolge der bisher einzige
bekannte planet der drei sonnen besitzt
kab wird von dem drei sterne system kelz
umkreis zb und kelz erhielt man bisher
für nur ein objekt betrachtet allerdings
rotieren die beiden sehr nah beieinander
für diese bewegung brauchen sie rund 30
jahre hält b&gt umrunden dann wiederum
kälte in ungefähr 4000 jahren und wo es
jetzt geld 4b kennt ihn bewegt sich
innerhalb von drei tagen einmal um kate
kate 4a b wird also von kälte und gc
umkreist und bestritt
als ein system mit drei sternen wie das
geldsystem wurde schon viermal gefunden
allerdings nie mit einem planeten im
bunde dieses ganz komplexe system ist
von uns aus gesehen übrigens gar nicht
so weit entfernt
gerade mal vier lichtjahre entdeckung
repetitive radio blitze muss revidiert
werden peter williams und edo berger vom
harvard smithsonian center für
astrophysik haben mit hilfe des
interferometer das very large telescope
vlt im märz gemessen radio blitze
genauer überprüft und erheben erhebliche
zweifel an der vermuteten herkunftsstaat
die radio emission dieser quelle geht
auf und ab aber verschwindet nie
vollständig das bedeutet dass es sich
nicht um die nachwehen des vaters
handeln kann so edel berger kosmische
radio blitze auch fast radio boss
genannt sind starke pulse im bereich der
radiowellen die bei kataklysmus
ereignissen für ein paar wenige
millisekunden entstehen oder kataklysmus
versteht man übrigens katastrophal und
maximal zerstörerische ereignisse und
mit dass im zusammenhang mit dem
weltraum steht da geht es dabei um
sachen wie supernovae oder kometen
einschläge woher die im märz gemessenen
strahlen jetzt aber stammen wenn nicht
von einem fast ray burst das wissen die
forscher noch nicht ganz genau
vermutungen zufolge könnte es flickr in
black hole sein also ein flackerndes
schwarzes loch die ursache könnte das
geben gewesen dann bestätigt ist das
aber noch nicht zitat das ist nun mal
teil des wissenschaftlichen prozesses
dass meine ergebnisse überprüft um zu
schauen ob sie standhalten so williams
neuer fall von ebola obwohl die
infektionskrankheit ebola erst vor
kurzem von der
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu nicht
mehr als globaler gesundheitsnotstand
benannt wurde kam es jetzt wieder zu
einem rückschlag in liberia ist eine 30
jährige frau an ebola erkrankt und daran
gestorben sie habe sich nachdem sie
verdächtige symptome bemerkte sofort in
eine klinik in paceville begeben
bei dem krankentransport nach monrovia
in die hauptstadt liberias starb die
frau allerdings die experten versuchen
nun sämtliche personen die mit der
frauen kontakt getreten sind zu finden
um diese auf den erreger zu untersuchen
seit dezember 2013 ausgebrochen ist
starben geschätzt 11.300 menschen an den
folgen der infektion rund
28.600 wurden infiziert die dunkelziffer
soll allerdings viel höher liegen in
guinea dem land in dem das virus zuerst
ausgebrochen war konnte im januar 2016
nachdem es 42 tage keine neue infektion
gegeben hatte
der status ebola frei vergeben werden
iberia dagegen verliert den status
wieder den das land erst im januar 2016
erlangt hatte zitat der kampf gegen
ebola ist nicht vorbei aber wir dürfen
die hoffnung nicht verlieren
das sagte die gesundheitsministerien
ministerin die vernissage im dezember
2015 jetzt beginnt es also wieder von
vorne
alle guten dinge sind 3 rakete zum
dritten mal erfolgreich gelandet dort
ist neben spacex eine der
erfolgreichsten privaten weltraum
unternehmen beide unternehmen streben
wieder verwendbare raketen an das
unternehmen blue origin kann jetzt ein
erfolg für sich verbuchen
zum dritten mal ist es gelungen eine
rakete des typs mit shepard erfolgreich
zu starten und zu landen
der chef von blue origin jeff bessers
dem auch amazon gehört der hält es sogar
für realistisch ab 2018 weltraum fliegen
flüge anbieten zu können nächstes jahr
werden allerdings erst mal testpiloten
in die höhe von 100 kilometern gebracht
in dieser höhe ist ja kurz
schwerelosigkeit möglich als auch der
blick auf die erde aus dem schwarz des
universums wieder start und die landung
aussahen
das sieht er jetzt
hier darf
die chapel spital
juni geben
der test
statt
ist es endlich gelungen die quelle der
rätselhafte neutrinos zu finden jetzt
ein klick zum science fiction
wirklich endlich gelungen die neutrino
herkunft zu klären
neutrinos werden häufig als geister
teilchen bezeichnet warum über neutrinos
weiß man bis dato noch so gut wie nichts
eine der größten fragen bezüglich dieser
teilchen ist die frage nach der herkunft
woher stammen diese winzigen
elementarteilchen forschern der
universität würzburg ist es jetzt
gelungen diese frage im fachmagazin
nature physics erstmals zu beantworten
das 2012 entdeckte neutrino big bird
stammen demnach von einem basar der bei
dem strahlungsausbruch der galaxie pk
sbb 14 24 strich 418 entstanden ist am
basar das heißt so viel wie blazing
quasi steller optik zeichnet sich
dadurch aus dass aus ihm eine hohe
emissionen anstrahlung hervorgeht ihre
beobachtung richtung fällt immer mit
denen des jets zusammen jets entstehen
wenn materie in das zentrum einer
galaxie seinem schwarzen loch stürzt im
zuge dessen entstehen meist zwei
gasströme welche dann jets genannt
werden der strahlungsausbruch habe sich
zur selben zeit und am selben ort wie
die entstehung des neutrinos ereignet
und das würde damit die neutrino quelle
darstellen die forscher berechnen
eine gerade mal 5 prozentige
wahrscheinlichkeit dass diese beiden
ereignisse zufällig vonstatten ging
jetzt aber noch mal kurz zurück zu dem
neutrinos wer sich in der schule schon
mal mit dem standardmodell der
elementarteilchen beschäftigen dürfte
der hat von diesen teilchen bestimmt
schon mal gehört neutrinos sind wie in
einer pressemitteilung der universität
würzburg beschrieben wird zitat die
schnellsten leichtesten und kontaktscheu
ssten elementarteilchen
weiter heißt es auch noch dass es erst
seit kurzem überhaupt möglich sei hoch
energetische neutrinos aus den tiefen
des universums nachzuweisen und obwohl
die zahl der neutrinos die zahl aller
atome im universum bei weitem übersteige
würden sie kaum in wechselwirkung mit
normaler materie stehen der neutrino
nachweis stelle dadurch eine große
wissenschaftliche herausforderung dar
am vierten dezember 2012 allerdings
konnten wissenschaftler des neutrino
observatoriums ice cube am südpol ein
gigantisches kosmisches neutrino finden
als jupp ist ein riesiger würfelförmige
detektor im ewigen eis der arktis mit
einer kantenlänge von einem kilometer
mehr als 5000 sensoren sind darin
enthalten
gigantisch sind auch die kosmischen
neutrinos die damit aufgespürt werden
kosmische neutrinos sind um ein
energiereicher als atmosphärische
neutrinos denn sie müssen durch den
kosmos reisen und dabei teilweise ganze
planeten durchqueren das damals
entdeckte kosmische neutrino big bird
und dass es auch heute geht hatte eine
energie von mehr als 2 peter
elektronenvolt
naja genauer gesagt handelt es sich
damit nicht um ein teilchen sondern eher
um ein gigantisches teil
das entdeckte neutrino hatte eine
energie von mehr als 2 peter
elektronenvolt zum vergleich ein
durchschnittliches molekül auf der erde
hat so eine energie von 0.03
elektronenvolt ein photonen des roten
lichts rund 2 elektronenvolt bei diesem
teil waren es nicht zwei millionen 30
mehr während zwei milliarden 30 mehr
werden zwei billionen aber es sind noch
einmal 3 02 milliarden elektronenvolt
der ursprung solche energetischer
kosmischer neutrinos wurde 2012 in der
sonne pool sein oder auch schwarzen
löchern in anderen galaxien vermutet
ganz falsch lag mal also vor vier jahren
nicht denn big bird entstand den
neuesten erkenntnissen zufolge bei dem
vorhin beschriebenen blaser ausbruch wie
genau das aus astronomischer sicht
ablief erklärt karl mannheim zitat
blasen in der lage in ihren jets
protonen auf relativistische energien zu
beschleunigen durch wechselwirkungen mit
licht können im zentralgebiet des basars
daraus spionen erzeugt werden
aus dem zerfall der prionen entstehen
dann sowohl gammastrahlen als auch
neutrinos von allen bekannten objekten
in der astrophysik sind nur die basare
im stand dem mit ice cube beobachteten
extraterrestrischen fluss von neutrinos
zu erklären zitat ende